[Musik]
das ist das vierte mal dass ist da ist
born ein film wird die geschichte von
einem alkoholiker der schon star ist und
eine frau entdeckte ganz da wird und
zwar in viel größerer als er jever ist
schon drei mal verfilmt worden mit 37 19
die gal und als die frau und james mason
als der alkoholiker dann noch 1976 mit
kris kristofferson als suppe und barbra
streisand als die wie singen kann und
jetzt eben mit bradley cooper selbst in
seiner eigenen regie als der mann der
dich kaputt trinkt und stefani joanne
angelina germanotta wie lady gaga als
die frau die es noch besser macht als
dreistes schon gemacht
ich singe meine eigenen songs nicht
warum ich fühle mich nicht wohl dabei
warum willst du dich nicht wohl war fast
alle sagen mir dass ihnen gefällt wie
ich singe aber dass ihnen nicht gefällt
wie ich aussehe
ich finde dich wundern ich habe den film
das erste mal auf dem filmfestival in
venedig gesehen und zwar als eine art
nachmittags zerstreut programm weil man
dachte hey bradley cooper totaler
klassiker lady gaga das wird bestenfalls
schräge und schlimmstenfalls super
peinlich und das war der nachmittag an
dem man die ganze zeit in venedig
filmkritikerin und filmkritiker
getroffen haben die somit halb
vorgehaltener hand gesagt haben liegt
das jetzt an mir liegt das an der sonne
liegt das am alkohol oder war das
wirklich wahnsinnig gut
und die antwort auf die ich mich
inzwischen eingependelt habe ist es war
wirklich wahnsinnig gut und es ist
wahnsinnig gut und man muss dafür
eingehen
weißt du mann
früher da war ich mir immer sicher das
was dir mal was wird dass es dir gut
gehen wird
jetzt mache ich mir zum ersten mal
tatsächlich es weniger darum geht
eigentlich dass bradley cooper als typ
gnädiger gar als frau entdeckt sondern
eigentlich mehr darum geht dass lady
gaga inso anheizt ihn so öffnet ihnen so
die möglichkeit gibt wirklich mal als
schauspieler auch gelernt zu sein weil
sie es ist dass man eigentlich sagen
kann der film handelt eigentlich davon
wie lady gaga bradley cooper ist
schauspieler und als regisseur entdeckt
ich wollte dich nur noch mal die musik
ist haben wir gut und was ich auch sagen
darauf weil ich die ganzen alten
schinken jetzt noch mal angeguckt habe
für den vergleich es ist der neben der
version mit judy garland wirklich bester
sind der dirigent version hat man noch
am ehesten ein gefühl dafür wie
bedrohlichen mensch ist der kaputt geht
also james mason hat halt einfach so ein
schatten von böse das ist für mich ewig
der lolita profi
[Musik]
das gibt dem eine zusätzliche dimension
die jetzt in dem film fehlt aber die
dynamik zwischen den beiden hauptfiguren
war also noch nie so interessant wie
jetzt in dem für wir machen das jetzt
sind wir einfach nur vertrag
es ist so viel care da drin ist es so
viel sorgfalt drin es ist eine
überlegung drin was heißt es eigentlich
ein star werden wovor hat er eigentlich
angst der ist nicht neidisch dass sie
erfolgreicher wird sondern er weiß wie
übel erfolg ist und wie gut es
andererseits ist und er sagte sie soll
die wahrheit sagen und du hast eben das
gefühl das ist ein märchenfilm
denn ich liegt also sowas geht offenbar
das hat natürlich kein glückliches ende
weil sonst wäre es ja genug
aber wenn man so prinzen und
prinzessinnen geschichten eigentlich
ganz gerne mag aber halt nicht an
geschmiert werden bilden muss man das an
[Musik]
[Applaus]